[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
players from 14 nations converge in st.
Louis as US chess champs calm presents
the third annual spring chess classic
hello chess fans welcome back the st.
Louis for day four of the 2019
spring chess classic my name is Ben
Simon and I'm joined as always by
Grandmaster Amnon Hambleton am on the
hair looks fabulous today as always well
and I can't reveal my secret until the
end of the tournament that's how we keep
our viewership all right and as you have
been asking in chat what is that on his
head you may never know but it's
fabulous we are in the midst of this big
event where we still don't have a clear
front-runner in each division and today
we have two different very store the two
very different stories to tell
in sections a and B first let's take a
look at our standings in Group A our
masters division we have Jeffrey Zhang
and alien is Nick and Aria and Terry at
the top and two of those players are
competing against each other today has
anything surprised you thus far in this
field among so far I don't know if it's
surprising but you definitely see the
the youth at the top of the table and
the seasoned vets near the bottom just
to start off one thing that is
surprising that I think maybe people
haven't noticed but has been happening
is actually Black has been scoring very
well in this event white has been losing
a lot of games we've seen a number of
players including Yvonne shook ray
Robson all losing with the white pieces
so it's it's may be the case where black
is actually performing very well in this
tournament so we'll have to see that
continues yeah you talked about the
youth this is really all about the youth
of this the seasonal classic series only
one person over the age of 35 has ever
actually won one of the fields that was
Victor malevsky last year let's take a
look at our group B section by ginchy as
expected the number one seed he's at the
top two-and-a-half or three
followed by a Nicolas theodoro who was
in the studio yesterday and any insight
that you gathered from Nicolas theodoro
during his interview well he definitely
seemed like he had the right attitude
approaching this tournament is he's off
to a great start tied for 1st and
looking to finalize that Grandmaster
title for himself and he remained quite
stoic and and really seemed to have a
good outlook wasn't getting ahead of
himself and tried to keep it calm and
just one game at a time so I think
that's healthy for for him going forward
and also we also had Sorkin who scored
his first point so the guys were chasing
some titles and norms in this tournament
are off to a good start yesterday it's
important to note that actually we saw
Sorokin up there with one point
Sorokin actually has already finished
his game today he brought himself to an
even score with a victory over his
opponent Dennis Ken rich so
congratulations to Sorokin Wow so there
you go he scored yesterday scored today
so that pretty much done does his first
two rounds right there yeah keep that
train rolling all right let's glance at
the tournament format if you're joining
us for the first time here's what's up
we're looking at 210 player round-robin
fields the time control 90 minutes for
the first 40 moves and then 30 minutes
are added on at move 41 for the
remainder of the game there is a 30
second increment from move number one so
the players have to take notation the
entire time and it makes losing on time
a little less likely actually a lot less
likely 30 move draw rule is in effect to
encourage fighting chess the players may
not agree to a draw before Black's
thirtieth move we encourage you to join
us all across social media YouTube
especially we got the YouTube chat open
today and we had 130 people waiting for
this show to start before even went off
the air and that is just absolutely
awesome
so we have 268 we've been having a north
of 900 for this event so this is just
really great
the lars von get says thanks for the
coverage st. Louis chess club and anhum
dog 1212 says is this in st. Louis yes
it's it's a presentation by the st.
Louis chess club outside of st. no thank
you your local don't give the st. Louis
club any ideas they could do that they
could do that
we hope the viewership numbers continue
to grow as the tournament gets more
exciting yes there's lots of lots of
stuff to play for yes and speaking of
stuff to play for we will take a look at
that later on but the games that are
going on right now
Group A let's take a glance at the
pairings for our masters division wisdom
Kasim Shauna versus liam lee now there's
talk about the stories in these games
and all five of these pairings have
played before as far as the first
matchup one oh and three draws in
classical chess in favor of cos and
jonov and in if you count blitz and
rapid three wins for each and three
draws so Kasim Jonathan Lee no strangers
to each other a Kobe on in Hanson we
were talking about this you said oh they
played so many times but according to
chess Gamescom they've never actually
sat down across from each other at the
board and played a rated game it's all
old fashioned that's old fashioned
nowadays meet online online is all that
counts
okay Jeffrey Zhang and REM tari tari has
him - and OH at the last - Tata Steel
events in the challengers sections Rey
Robson and Benjamin Bach Robson beat
Bach at 2010 chorus that's ancient
history so let's let's run it back and
see what happens this time and our key
matchup today is iliyan is Nick versus
uh I pardon me I read them out of order
our key metric today is indeed Jeffrey
Zhang vs. re ant re the match where tari
has has beaten in the last two years at
tata steel so we'll see you know Jeffrey
Zhang has really been coming up the
ranks we've basically seen hit and grow
here in st. Louis even though he's from
Dallas let's take a glance of the game
and see where we are in Group A right
and though those are some big results
you know it's not not like they played
when you know they were kids and and now
that everything's gonna be different I
mean they are kids so yeah
- and o4r Ataris
definitely something that no doubt these
players are both aware of we see the
game here as you see the players pretty
pretty even on time slide time avenge
for our D and sorry as we see quite a
lot of pieces liquidated from this one
the opening there was was quite
symmetrical to start off as you just go
back a couple moves we can see just this
Queen trade by by Geoffrey initiated by
Geoffrey and I mean when you get a
position like this as black you know
these pawns on the Kings side they're
only really scary when there's maybe a
queen on the board and a sort of threats
against the king but after that Queen
trade on c6 I'm looking at this position
and saying wait a minute I mean Black
has doubled rooks on the D file how can
this be bad for fitori
if you envision a position where maybe
all the rooks get traded then maybe I
could say okay maybe the King comes in
to e4 and we start to push all these
pawns and actually White has a space
advantage across the board Queen side
and the Kings side so he has these
dreams of doing that but as long as star
e keeps a rook let's say at the very
least on the board I think he's doing
just fine here and with that control of
the the D file Jeffrey's trying to say
look I'm covering this square I'm
covering this square and if you play
rook d3 where are you going next so he's
trying to say look you can have the D
file but you're not using it whereas you
know by the other the other way of
looking at it is that it's re controls
the D file the only way to challenge it
is to trade all the rooks now can he
really find time to arrange King the e2
and rook d1
I don't know rook d3 rook h3 move in
that case would put a lot of pressure on
the h2 pawn so I'm not sure that that
Geoffrey can sort of wrangle control of
this position but if he can
he definitely has you know the optimist
again game with all that space but right
now it's looking it's looking very equal
as we catch up to the current position
and Chari is just played to move h5 and
he's trying to say look if you play g5 I
have this long-term idea it may be
trying to bring a Knight to f5 by
playing g5 white is also going to get in
control the e5 square so both sides are
trying to get an outpost for their
Knight where the pawns cannot kick that
night out and
it looks offhand like like black is you
know after this age five move should be
securing some squares for the night has
control of the D file it means that
whites night can't move so easily
because that rook D to check is gonna be
very annoying so whites kind of tied
down to defending the the current
position and I prefer audience position
just slightly the I was wondering about
is it is it reasonable to think that
tari might want to move the night on c4
so you can bring the rook down to the
second rank I was looking at maybe
pushing the beep on that doesn't seem to
be an option anymore after a five right
and I think Jeffrey was sort of two
steps ahead of that whole idea he
immediately played a four a five early
on just because he knows that this night
on c4 is kind of a key to the whole
position here I mean he has to have that
he has to have that partner or that
night there excuse me otherwise it's
it's big trouble so I mean g5 looks like
already the the knight can reroute what
do we actually see in the games I
believe we have some moves quite a lot
of moves actually since the position he
played the move G takes h5 and looking
at the board if you have to play a move
like that I feel like there's already
something wrong with the position if you
have to play g h5 simply brooke takes
and I mean these pawns now disconnected
there must have been something he didn't
like about g5 here because we look at
the follow up he actually goes rook do
you want and he's trying to say look you
take my pawn on h4 and and what I have
some some compensation here with the
idea of ninety-six so we see some some
liquidation here if ninety-six
let's say King seven nine takes b7 black
has this move if rook F 2 we can take
that and that's a free Brooklyn d1 and
if the King moves you know we can trade
rooks maybe grab that pawn over there on
V 2 White has the C pawn and hanging
black has the a pawn hanging you know
this line goes pretty far down and we
might see quite a lot of simplifications
here but I can't see I can't see tari
ending up on the worst side of this as
he's just taken on h4 and you always
have this check on h2 in the
pocket right so this looks good for for
black right now I think Jeffrey would be
you'd be happy to hold the draw at this
point all right well that's our key
matchup so far in Group A let's jump on
over to group B and check out the
matchups that are happening today at us
chest champs calm remember one of these
games is already over but the ones still
in progress
Stein Grimson versus me stop bars poets
versus katana vegans she versus Sergey
Arenberg the one that's finished Denis
CAD rich versus Alexi Sorokin and our
key matchup today is Christian Carillo
versus Nicolas theodoro and a reminder
for group B unlike Group A these are all
first time ever matchups these players
are roughly unfamiliar with each other
as far as actual play on the board so
let's see how gorilla and theodoro are
doing yeah we have this game underway
here I also got a glance in person Ben
as we snuck up for a coffee
so this that's what happens whenever our
coffee is stolen from the basement we
steal it back from the tournament hall
yeah yeah it was a great opportunity to
see the players i for a not yet I went
up there to check the board and nothing
else so I had to get a glimpse of the
key matchup in person and actually the
last couple moves kind of paint the
picture if we go back a little bit
because in the opening I think there was
a lot of simplifications here this one
started out pretty pretty tame just as a
default Bishop f4 London system and we
actually got into this position where
after 94 takes takes F 3 F 6 just kind
of a funny position where we've got this
bishop pinning the night we've got this
bishop hanging and then everybody's
pieces are suddenly hanging in the
center of the board there and what a
nightmare to calculate what happens here
but both players take two pieces and we
have opposite bishops in this position
and Carrillo follows up with the move
Queen f3 after black castles takes on f4
he's gonna have to displace his own king
here as a result and just looking at the
time as well then I think that basically
paints the whole picture 30-minute time
advantage for black here as we see
bishop before check forcing the King to
move something you don't normally want
to do if you don't have to and although
there's opposite bishops in the position
let's pay attention to the fact that
currently these Queens are still on the
board and that means there's going to be
great attacking chances for black we've
got this pawn hanging on d4 for the
moment the F file is open directly
towards the King and as we see the game
progressed here rook d1 rook e8 h6 and
all of a sudden black is opening lines
in the position here he's got an open e
file an open G file now what does
korilla have he has that long term
weakness on f5 so if his King can
survive we have ideas like getting this
Bishop to h3 or d3 and really just
taking that pawn on f5 and all of a
sudden taking that v h7 starts to hang
and blacks King starts to get in danger
so it's really whether or not this
Bishop on b4 can enter the action right
now there's just no way to do that if I
place c5 hoping that you might take you
know give me this of course that's not
necessarily gonna happen d5 is always an
option or a3 and that Bishop is very
nearly trapped on the side of the board
do you ever take there's always b4 so
not a very easy position to activate
your dark square Bishop here and
although gorilla is down on the clock
here I have to say the last couple moves
seem to be slightly positive for him he
has to be very concerned about the
mcgillich rook to e4 here potentially
hitting that D pawn but again long-term
I feel like gorilla has very good
counter play here and although he's low
on the clock ban I actually think maybe
korilla has has a preferred position
here maybe not preferred but maybe
easier to play the bishops gonna come to
d3 and if that rook gets to h1 and I
take on h7 all of a sudden maybe the
tables turn and why it's actually doing
well so despite the time advantage I
think black Nicholas here has to
actually be be quite accurate and
maybe that's why he's spending some time
in the current position gorilla down to
four minutes to theodoros 32 yeah that
was for the first thing that you showed
me on there with the the Queen f3 first
thing I noticed was all queens coming
down there the rooks maybe gonna come up
to h3 and screwed over and all man
blacks in trouble but it's not that
simple of course no I mean you've got
this open h-file so it's just a question
of whether this rook can get there
because of course it has a very
important job which is defending that
Center pawn but this Bishop here if it
can't find itself on this diagonal
sometime soon I've really start to
wonder you know where does that Bishop
belong because II 7 d6 or these aren't
very promising diagonals here right okay
well before we go around the horn and
take a look at all of the games let's
see what the players are fighting for
first the prize fund for group a $22,000
total on the Lion with their champion
walking away with $6,000 and our B group
$14,000 prize fund the champion walks
away with 4,000 and I know it's really
early on still we're only halfway there
but there will be playoffs in the case
of a tie for first place and we've seen
playoff several times in the history of
the seasonal classic it's very exciting
it will be on the last day the same as
round nine so that's why we're starting
a little bit early yep so very exciting
stuff to look forward to one of the
games I wanted to look at first I always
like to look at the ones that seem like
they're a little bit imbalanced as far
as the advantage yes ready to end soon
yes Group A let's take a look at Rey
Robson and Benjamin Bach as once again
these two players have played once
before but it's ancient history back in
2010 course with Robson getting the
victory where do we stand right now a
lot well Benjamin Bach I'm not sure if
he's still standing at all in this
current position
he's down a piece but he's definitely
got compensation here in the form
these two pawns here I have to say that
that I feel like long term this this
might be winning for white but it's not
going to be easy now one of the things
to keep in mind and this might seem like
you know really far off but it's what
these players are probably considering
at the moment is that this bishop in
this pawn do not work well together on
the h8 square so in the event that
certain pawns get liquidated you know
you can't rely on that bishop in each
pawn working together in the long term
down the h-file so the the pawn
structure is shattered here for white on
the Kings side which means that you know
black has easy targets like rook before
trying to take this pawn you know you're
gonna try to hang on to these pawns as
long as possible here if you're black
try to survive but I mean he's he's down
20 minutes on the clock
however for Benny Minear the moves are
actually quite easy you're down a piece
he pretty much just shuffling defending
your pawns nothing special
whereas Ray Robson is gonna see you know
what is his technique is capable of here
it was actually iliyan is Nick who came
in for an interview and was really
touting Ray's and game knowledge and how
he was really aware of whether certain
position was winning or drawing so maybe
Ray has already seen a similar type of
position and the these do happen a lot
in studies and things that players might
be practicing where you have a bishop
versus a lot of pawns and those can
often be very very tough to convert so
we'll see if Ray knows anything about
this endgame but even if it's a draw of
course he's gonna he's gonna try to win
this now in this particular situation I
know that the white bishop is under
attack it needs to be defended or move
but we're about to see the king is
coming to this game wouldn't you say oh
yeah no this this is a fully fledged
endgame we're gonna see black try to
target the f4 pawn while we can probably
arrange his pawns either h5 like that or
maybe F v g6 h7 target the f4 pawn try
to trade as many pawns as you can that
would be ideal for for Benjamin here and
if you can for example give away all
five of blacks pawns for just the three
pawns from white we would have the
classic rook and Bishop against rook
endgame
technically it's a draw and you know
he's still gonna play that on try to win
it as a lot of players managed to do but
Benjamin has a lot of drawing outs here
that he can try to access so I don't
think this is a clear win and in fact I
don't even know if it's actually winning
but definitely the only winning chances
are in raised court here over in Group
II he had in Stein Grimson versus
Alexander Mista
we have Iceland versus Poland look at
those bishops those black bishops right
there buzzing down they look deadly am i
right Amon am i right please say I'm
right well in comparison to the white
bishops they certainly do I would say
you are correct sir
been fine well he's usually correct
famous and gold ninety-five here doesn't
work because your queen is hanging why
is a knight on beat three attacked by
upon someone tell me that if I play pawn
takes what is the big idea of coming
from Poland here I'm gonna take back be
down one full entire piece momentarily I
mean how many times do you actually like
let's say attack the knight and have the
guy go to the square you just move from
it's very strange you attack the knight
you expect him to go back and then you
know if you did go back here they don't
have to want your bishops maybe move
like 95 and this is a position that
really starts to look good for white
this is a classic type of maroc see bind
these bishops don't look good when they
have nothing to attack and when there's
a knight sitting in their face so this
really creative 93 prevents this whole
idea so if I take pawn takes the rooks
under attack now we're kind of forced
here to play the move rook c1 because
any other move drops that night with
devastating effect so focusing on is
forced but then we have to see what is
Alexander Mistah intending here there's
a couple moves to consider first of all
sometimes you have an idea like b2 and
then if I take let's say you're walking
into this pin
and I could play rook takes here and we
could try to say okay look this Knight
is pinned maybe I'm gonna win the knight
next but after rook III I don't know
Bishop d4 rook c8 are both moves to
pressure that night one of those moves
is probably gonna work but I'm just not
sure if it's enough you know that knight
on c3 can be defended even though it's
weird Bishop II wanna White's working
hard to defend that night but he is
hanging on to it so that's an idea of
course the other idea is to just simply
take that pawn straight away rook takes
and maintain this pawn and say look the
idea is simply be to the roof comes down
to a 1 and these bishops are basically
non-participants in the whole attack as
you mentioned those bishops while
they're extremely good now and they're
helping escort that pawn all the way
down the board shades of the game
yesterday that we saw that pawns sneak
all the way to c7 against mr. himself
and now he he's thinking well let me get
one of those and see how it works
you mentioned the the situation where
the Queen is pinned are the night the
night has been the Queen's on b2 right
and everything is just White's pieces
are now just defending everything let's
say what do you think what yeah do you
think Mike can really hold that up I
mean it seems kind of iffy to me after
the rookie 3 Bishop before rookie 3 so
here we would have a choice whether I
want to start with rook c8 or not and I
was thinking Bishop d4 is also 90th and
43 we could take take and you know I can
go here I could go here either way the
problem is I'm gonna put my Queen here
and although it's not pretty I've got
three pieces defending and your bishops
on the light square so you just can't
add any more firepower to to the c3
square so in a position like this we
would certainly be able to hold it and
if you don't play Bishop b4 and you just
go here you're threatening to take this
first of all Bishop II won again not
pretty but we we do have enough pieces
defending and that bishop on e6 can't
add anything to the attack so while it
doesn't look pretty it's it's quite
possible that white can sit here and
hold it and sort of squirt him out
eventually which is why I wasn't
thinking that maybe that was blacks best
option maybe just rooked
see four and sort of keep this pawn
instead of sacrificing it well I know
that the players have just holes bullets
doubt several moves I saw them in the
camera where are we at now yeah we're
actually right on that line takes and
again why are we taking here because
there's still that Bishop takes c3 move
maintained in the position there's also
this pawn just hanging and if you don't
take it you can I have to take it later
otherwise I'm just crashing through
taking everything so it's kind of like
his hand is forced here captures and we
do see that line rook takes c4 he's not
going for b2 because it did look to me
like white can hang on there so this
looks very good for Alexander Mistah
offhand it looks like these bishops are
not participating and I feel like black
is crashing through successfully here
that pawn is going to be escorted with
rook a 1 coming the loose knight on c3
and the two bishops helping that pawn
become a queen and I think mister might
win a game in sacrificial fashion with a
pawn almost on the 7th 8th ranked just
like his last round defeat so learning
from your mistakes man well and those
are amongst the prettiest ways to win
games so the most satisfying yes
satisfying okay I want to take a look at
Group A Liam Lee as black against Bruce
Timm Kasim Jean ah've this is the former
feed a world champion Kasim jonov
against the man who actually in st.
Louis we first heard of him as an
alternate a lot of people don't know he
was an alternate for the very first
Sinquefield Cup thankfully we didn't
have to call upon his services but this
guy is world class right now so let's
let's see what's happening here well no
surprise if you take a look at the pawn
structure that we see in this opening
right here a lot of players would be
able to identify that this is actually
from a Berlin and it was Kasim Janov who
played at Berlin
I played into a Berlin rather against
Eric Hansen earlier and they had a draw
on their game so this is not the first
time that Kasim janeth has pulled out
the Berlin as weapon so he's going to it
again
he's down 33 minutes here in the current
position and
I have to say with these loose nights on
the fourth-ranked with that doubled
isolated pawn structure on the H file
you know these are not dangerous pawns
sometimes you can have double pawns
that's fine if they're dangerous they're
moving up the board quickly you know
they can be it can be very tough to deal
with but right here we've got that night
block gating we got the rook ready to
take the C pawn as well as you know
these Knights like I said are just loose
here that can't move one without losing
the other type of thing
Bishop to b7 is a major idea pinning
that night to the king with the time
pressure plus all these factors I think
that laQuan Liam is actually maybe doing
well here I don't know what about 95
aiming for the c7 pawn 95 so if 95
happens I guess one of the first things
that comes to my mind is is do we play
Bishop here and hit that night with the
idea that if you go grab my pawn
obviously you lose your your entire
night there so maybe he's gonna go 95
Bishop b7 and with that Knight attacks I
don't see don't see how me because if I
play f3 I feel like black can maybe just
take this and and do well in this
position it pumps look like they're
about equal we got two extra pawns over
here for 4 black and the two extra pawns
for white are kind of sitting in the H
file so I think I prefer black in that
position now here though and by the way
we do see 95 on the board so this is
actually what look long M has to deal
with at the moment this should be seven
looks does look like one of the better
moves let's say if 93 there's always f5
and you're just pinned to the King so I
feel like Bishop e7 is my gut reaction
to that but he's got a lot of time to
think here and he does not have to rush
into Bishop d7 here when potentially
there there is another move on the board
rook takes c4 for example 9 takes e7
then you have ideas like maybe Bishop e7
now hitting that night forcing f3 and
ideas like maybe rook down to c2
take v2 I feel like there's a lot of
forcing options for black that that he's
definitely considering here especially
when he knows that roost em probably
just doesn't have enough time to
necessarily calculate everything to the
end right now
well this just looks really good for
Liam Lee does Kasim jonov have anything
well I think that the reason that I'm so
confident for black is you know because
aesthetically or visually these pawns
don't look like they're going anywhere
and you know it's it's tough to to sort
of maintain the position when you've got
these threats to deal with you're losing
upon rooks II to objectively I actually
think it might not be that bad for white
for Kasim Jon off here but when I factor
in all the the small advantages for
black like the time situation and just
how easy it is to play I do feel like
like Black has is the one playing for
something here and laQuan liam is is
having a thing here but feels like a
very comfortable position to think in
where you're not that concerned about
some of the options here they all look
very decent for black Bishop e7 as well
as we rotate c4 seems like black is is
doing well here all right well let's
move on and in group a we have the all
Ukraine matchup Hylian is Nick vs.
Vasilyev on the legend we've got a
knight each and the rook each and to
pass pawns on a and B we have here I
mean this is this position is completely
liquidated I would take Nick well again
it's it's almost like there's a formula
for these games in the a group one
player may be slightly better the other
player at 30 minutes down on time I mean
it's like they're all agreeing to play a
certain way when you have a slightly
worse position you also have to be down
30 minutes I think it's a requirement
here in the a group so is this really
that bad though
of course I'm kind of just jabbing there
because for example King Jiwon has just
been played rook check can be played
this can probably have to go to f2 and
then if rook check again this King has
to
go to g1 or f1 let's say we go to f1
with the idea here that could play 91
even in this case you have to have to
look at that night on g2 and it is such
a bad piece it can't move anywhere if
you play 91 without me checking you I
have made me an 83 coming into position
the h2 pawn hangs so I feel like this is
that type of position where the counter
play from black is is gonna be more than
enough to deal with these pawns I'm not
concerned about these passed pawns going
up the board here if you ever play a4 is
always rook a to and you're just
covering that palm long term the knight
stops the b-pawn from moving and this
Knight really has trouble joining the
action bends so I'm actually not
concerned here for Vasily there's nine
moves whole time control he's got two
minutes but I think it's generally very
easy to play with the black pieces here
so I'm not that concern but with time
situation maybe that sparks ilya to to
play in a certain way where you might
play like 91 give up upon try to get
these pawns going 93 before but to me
it's just it's just not enough and I
think I think you've on hooks got more
than enough compensation here for the
one pawned that he's down well thank you
for clearing that up
yeah I was like yeah Jake's got this
passed pawns right it's a fast way to
connect advanced pawn right you don't
see those guys and not do well very
often but I am really scared here with
the King cut off by the rook and the
fact that this Knight can bounce around
even just the idea of advancing some
ponds or getting the King into the
action
I feel like even shark is not terribly
concerned here rook on the seventh is
pretty good here
yet both the guys got it but the
difference actually is that if this pawn
on f7 was on f5 I'd be a lot more
concerned for black because then I'm
actually cut off which is what we have
for white so vice versa if that pun was
on f2 then we see actually it's totally
different then I could play h4 I could
play 93 Knight f4 so many different ways
to get my knight into the action a
shelter for my king but because I've got
that f4 pawn pushed which you know was
just a product of the position I think
that was moved much earlier in the game
there's unfortunate the Kings cut off
and I don't think Yvonne cooks that
concerned what move as he just played
he's just
to move rook to be - why is that so
powerful well nice connected pawns there
mr. Ben but you can't move them and if
you can't move them they're not very
useful
they look nice though they look nice
yeah yeah they look nice so there you go
I think you've on trick is is
comfortable here and sometimes you know
god forbid it can actually be difficult
to play with the white pieces here
because those two pawns can't move at
all and you feel like your knight can't
move you feel like the Knights getting
in dangerous dangerous so I I don't
think new Janek is looking at this
position and saying oh this should be
totally winning but it's very difficult
I think he's actually erring on the side
of okay this is quite equal and maybe I
even also have to be careful all right
well I like this hop skip pattern we
have going here so let's go over to
group B by ginchy I get Sergei Ehrenberg
the Chinese player by is here in st.
Louis for the first time it's one of the
good things about these classic events
surrogate Arenberg no stranger to st.
Louis whatsoever formerly of Israel it's
been playing in US Championships I think
he played in two of them starting in
2013 okay what's going on in this game
well we see the formula being followed
here white is slightly better and blacks
down thirty minutes on the clock so
seems accurate basically that's my
blanket statement for every single game
in this tournament a and B groups we see
a B group following suit as Sergei
Ehrenburg really is down 30 minutes on
the clock he's down one pawn here we do
have opposite bishops but make no
mistake by James she is doing extremely
well here we can see an exchange here
now Ehrenburg of course is gonna be
looking to hold a draw here but I think
he's got his work cut out for him I'm
willing to say that I think vyjit she's
just just completely winning in this
position here Ben you've got that pawn
loose on g4 there's always ideas like
Knight to f4 Bishop h4 is coming as well
with a nasty pin on the knight on f6 so
in this position it's very very
difficult for Arenberg and I think by
June she is coasting to what could be
just another victory here in the B
and Aaron Berger unfortunately for him
another loss coming up winless thus far
in the event he's had two draws and a
loss you know he hasn't he hasn't gotten
that pep in his step yet I saw him after
they ran out last night and well it kind
of beats you down write it down a little
bit he played a very interesting game
against gorilla and I was seeing
upstairs gorilla and him we're doing
post-mortem and you know those games are
very exciting and they're very
interesting and I know that that's sort
of his style of play when you come out
on the wrong end of the result in too
many of those games does dishearten you
a little bit so we hope that's not the
case but you know Ehrenberg in this game
just to sort of go back a little bit if
we check the opening here we can see
right off the bat that actually he
sacked a pawn with e5 and I just sort of
illustrating the the style that he's
playing in he's sacking upon he's he's
going for it but at the end of the day
when your opponent just finds these
these good sort of classical reputations
- your moves and sort of takes all the
pawns you offer and then handles the
complications you know it gets tough
right they you're trying to spice things
up trying to make it interesting your
opponent just playing good move after
good move defending and then all of a
sudden what he found himself with was a
position where it liquidated and you
know you just get this one pawn down
position where you're suffering and then
you're down all that time that you spent
trying to calculate and now he's in this
position and they have made a few more
moves g4 at night at for Bishop f7 and
this was the position I was talking
about where Bishop h4 is just a major
move here pinning the knight
if you don't do anything II five there's
a lot of game-winning moves here winning
that night if you do something let's say
like Bishop here rook h8 I don't know if
maybe that's like the only move or
something but let's say one example is
that I could just take this and take the
pawn now I'm up to pawns
I'm sure there's better moves than what
I'm suggesting right now but this is an
example of like okay we just win those
two pawns of course here's Bishop a two
so I'm not too sure about that but I am
pretty confident that some combination
of either the move e5 here hitting that
night or Bishop Age fourth in some order
is is going to be
is gonna be lethal I'm getting word that
we have another result in Group B as
Alexander Mistah has defeated he had in
Stein crimson Stein crimson actually
looks like his his white fleet was yeah
tweet can we bring that game up here oh
sure he is behind enemy lines that one
Mike he does not look happy that one
again basically that's a similar story
to miss this last game it's it's so
funny he really repeated the same idea
that you've lost you again it's these
bishops over here they're just not
playing they're not participating these
guys are doing everything supporting the
pond getting ready to play Bishop a to
supporting the pawn once again and all
he does was trade the rooks and it just
makes a new queen and it's just game
over like that so completely missed the
idea I think of right here maybe three
it's it's really funny you play a 493
the guys pawn is on b3 he moves it
forward you go to the square that he was
just on and you know you just crashed
through as he pointed out those bishops
ecigs and f6 so strong and we just saw
the time advantage plus the crushing
position just insurmountable for Stein
Grimson is Alexander Mistah with a
really nice bounce back after a tough
loss to the lowest-rated seed he comes
back with a win so that's that's a great
game yeah I think we should definitely
talk to grandmaster me stay if possible
for the first time in this event yes
okay so we've looked at most of the
games but let's take a look at something
we haven't yet the believe it or not
first time over the board matchup a
cobia and Hansen in Group A right yeah
they they have played quite a number of
games but surprisingly that most of them
have actually been in the pro league is
a Montreal chess bras have played
against the st. Louis Archbishop's right
chesley numerous times and I believe
that's where most of the encounters have
happened that's where chess games calm
says they've all happens right before of
them exactly so here they are playing
they feel like they're not strangers to
each other but then they actually maybe
are but of course var is a very familiar
face
Eric and Eric and him definitely know
each other quite well it looks like we
joined this one probably ten minutes too
late I'm willing to say there was a
30-minute time advantage but now it's
only 20 so what what I can say here
though is that almost all their matches
have been a grünfeld is var is a d4
player through and through or even if he
goes for some sidelines
Eric usually goes for it the grin felt
against var at least I think most of
their games have been like that so not a
grunt felt today though it was actually
a tirage variation and just going over
the last couple moves here we can see
massive trades in the middle of the
board including a rook trade and when
you get a position like this sometimes
black is is just preferred because early
on in the game well these are great puns
they gain space they restrict to pieces
as you trade more and more pieces off
suddenly hey that's a free pawn right
there that's a free pawn right there
Black's got the outside pass pawn
potential so this Knight just doesn't
have anywhere to go as soon as you move
oops you lose upon so White's position
suddenly is not very easy to play and
after Knight f4 there's big ideas like
Queen takes here you know oops maybe
Queen g4 there's lots of pressure on the
G to square as well as this night being
hanging so I think this is a good
position for for Eric and let's take a
look at the move that was just played
was Knight f4 g3 got that Queen don't
forget about it guarding the knight
their thankfully and after Knight d3
black saying okay look now the knight is
attacked he can't go grab my pawn and
Knight takes e5 as a threat as well so
it seems like to me especially
considering that time advantage that
Eric Hanson is pushing here with the
black pieces and I think VARs just
played them with King g2 and that's on
the board very very logic if let's say
that a black took the pawn on e5 so
right now you take the pawn on e5 mm-hm
if let's say trade hates oh there's an
extra pawn hanging on H that was the
issue well there's plenty hanging here
but I have to be sure it's black that
I'm taking this pawn because I never
want to have a position where white
takes here and actually
somehow I had two on one over there but
he ends up with the past bond so that's
the only thing that I simply can't allow
but in a position like this okay
actually Eric's just made a move Queen
to g4 in a position like this we've
actually seen Hanson refrain from taking
some of these ponds that have been
hanging for the last couple moves h5s
been hanging you know for the last four
or five moves he hasn't taken it he 5
has been hanging as well he hasn't taken
it what he's doing is he's trying to
create threats around the king and var
as we can see you know scrambling those
moves out he has to be very very careful
here for example one a7 there's ideas
like Knight f4 check and Queen takes on
f3 so he's actually played the move
Queen b7 in this position after queen g4
queen b7 and again you can see he moved
with 6 seconds on the clock so this is
gonna be a very tough hold for var who
is facing a lot of these pawns hanging
in the position objectively I think he's
probably you know okay I think black is
slightly better no question but because
of the time and because of the pressure
that Hansen can put on White's position
sort of carefree you know he he doesn't
have to make good moves he can make any
moves as long as he has a threat I think
that black is really preferred here
because of that for those of you
wondering why you saw VARs time tick
down to one second and then up to 36
seconds well there's a few seconds
margin of error with these digital
clocks and also with each move the
players will get 30 seconds added on to
their clocks that's what we mean when we
say a 30-second increment well your
choice I'm on go to whatever game you
want because our interview is here and
we're gonna have Alexander Mistah in the
studio in just a moment fantastic all
right well yeah you can see the game
here Eric just played Queen to c4 but
there's there's a few games that we
haven't taken a look at and over in the
B group I think the one of the most
interesting games that we didn't quite
jump to yep it was actually the game
between and rebars pullets against
Gregory katana and we see the position
here as actually it's one of the only
games that we've jumped to where there
isn't a massive time advantage both
players around nine or
it's a piece and Kadena here has the
bishop pair but he appears to be down
upon
however momentary that may be a three is
hanging as well White's got this this
pollen on f7 so let's say here King aged
seven and it's actually black to play
here so yeah this position was one of
the only ones that we didn't jump to yet
now offhand I mean sometimes in
positions like this it's it's always
tempting to throw a move like Queen g3
in the position and with an idea like
Bishop h3 and you know basically just
showing off how many pins you could
possibly create here so don't know if
he's getting ambitious looking at stuff
like that but that's always one of the
first things that that you look at in a
position like this but in the meantime
we are gonna take a look at the game
between Alexander Mistah and Hayden
Stein Grimson is we have mister joining
us in the studio thanks for joining and
you you came off a loss yesterday and
it's really nice obviously after you
have a tough game to come back and win
so I'm sure you're happy with the result
yeah it was not an easy game today
especially that the first two games I
was winning and in the first one I
missed
easy win and in the second one I also
missed maybe it was not so easy but
right but I knew that
I could win somewhere but I could have
fun
fortunately and and I branded a few most
right there the game yesterday against
Sorokin was quite interesting as he
actually had a pawn pushed all the way
down the board I seemed like you almost
learned from that and then used it today
to your advantage
yeah so the postpones are very hard to
stop yes
so if you don't mind take us through the
game maybe from the start some of the
important moments in your game today
defendant as opposed to Sicilian an
insta-mom or ultrastructure right yeah
always a solid solid structure for white
but you came quickly with this idea
Knight to d7
what are they play the one game against
the F ski a few years ago so I still
remember something good good ok you had
some ideas and let's see here this says
no no 3 I didn't like this this move
literally they played before and it's
very suspicious to take the pawn shops
III at night before so I plan to or 2096
instead of this and lagging my game Roxy
won a 5/5 for sure yeah
in just the middle game from there so
you won for this move f3 which yeah I
guess it's just a little bit slow said
it yes no no I have some good options
and I think that divorce is good enough
because I exchanged one case and I don't
have problems with space no but the
Bishop d7 maybe I was
the faster this move we consider yeah if
I take a 5-4 B 6 and the same time lag
in the game say yeah because you always
have a minister exchange and that could
be shortened in my position should be in
good shape so sure Bishop g7 very they
put Bishop on c6 in in the other line
and Bishop d7 Bishop c6 but now I think
I didn't have to play like like this and
bishop on e6 ranks because maybe you're
a few moves ahead of everyone I try to
calculate it the most comparing to the
main line in desperation so I couldn't
find one one move for me so I had to
change something yeah Bishop e6 Rickey
one I was surprised with this move I've
expected Bishop e3 followed by 22 and if
I play Queen b6 the rock said transposed
to the main line the plank in the earth
Queen of 885 King gate 7 well of course
the White has some like Roxy to be one
and try to push way before yeah so it
just be a pretty standard game at that
point
the game you're always thinking like do
I have an extra move my bishop on e6 is
not on c6 but yeah rook e1 is bit slow
seems like maybe the plan is to play 95
from a moment and
[Music]
take control over if Island Press on a
seven so I had to be careful but so far
standard most standard yeah obstacle
this was also strange move it seems like
he's following maybe like a few plans
combining them together yes if you want
a total double rogue on violent and she
was waiting with 95 as long as possible
yes so now I work in the earth we should
be fine now
now it can be you know in 95 and rock
ce2 training on the fire yeah that can
be be weak so you kick the bishop yes
and into 5 so I wanted to set the
battery on the
22:02 short of six triple English now
it's it's important moment I saw that
trick before - it seems like this this
whole idea of working on Bishop F on g3
Bishop g2 is quite quite a lot of moves
yes I managed to find the country but a
force yeah right here
because now now I don't have the truth
93 but yes if I fall before maybe maybe
I can try something like this design
before before and 96 and now both palms
are hanging if 95 can take the 5 and I
wasn't sure about the 5 now very dynamic
yet when it is suspicious Roxy to
consider night before
and then losing hell versed advice
bishops no no it looks better but I also
had some ideas to transfer my Bishop to
d6 and now because no writing is a
little bit exposed I think it's clear
that Bishop probably belongs up before
default a forehead and I keep the
tension and maybe go be 57 and you shop
c6 and I maybe I don't have to take on
d5 okay maybe Photoshop tutorials but I
think it's clear the specific I was
chosen for what disposition how to
continue
we're still thinking about the right
time but Bishop Jim Joyce is too slow
and and it is fr and ya know Broca's
position is better yeah yeah these
bishops are doing much better than these
and after before it's a really nice move
93 that obviously you seen he maybe
would yeah yeah very devious
yes might be three and and really
there's just there's nothing to do with
why you're forced to this or yeah the
ponies too strong you know I can there's
no my pieces and the bishops are not on
what bishops are not so strong yeah and
do you see any better resistance or it's
probably no no I didn't see because if
for example not be one here I have row
Cato and the shop enough to is falling
right before before yes even if white
plays d5 and be 55 and it'll be five and
then this position is still worse
because I have menopause and of course
these three poses upon is very important
and
like yeah it's really tough to hold at
this point so I mean he played 92 but
here it's a pretty easy plan just all
the pieces are working greenness is
defending the kink yes half were played
so like I said yeah I was really funny
to see you actually use the same idea
from last game and there you go it
worked it worked out really nicely so
yeah finally
yeah yeah so obviously win is a great
result for for you today and you know
Congrats Congrats on the gaming thanks
for taking the time to thank you I the
studio okay thanks
all right that was Alexander Mistah who
just took us through his victory against
Hayden Stein Grimson from Iceland today
in the B group and we will continue to
take a look at some of the games still
ongoing here who do we have I think it
was the game of Hansen and Cobian was in
some serious time trouble maybe we can
jump back to that and see what has
happened they still haven't hit move 40
here I think we were around this area
Queen c4 e6 was played in order for vara
to sort of coordinate his pieces again
and get that night into f5 it looks like
he made his last move with 4 seconds on
the clock still three moves to play
until time control you know bar is
definitely going to gonna make that but
long term here if Hansen can arrange a
queen trade we have one extra pawn for
black and the idea to get a passport on
the Queen side let's see what what var
can do here seems like he's very
comfortable in time pressure I mean he's
pretty experienced and a very strong
blitz player himself so no issues there
but the real problem is you know what
happens once you make the time control
is you're faced with a position that is
definitely worse for
for white here's your down upon and if
you can keep those Queens on though you
can make some real threats against the
g7 square so I think for the cost of a
pawn Kobe in has made his position a
little bit easier to play which i think
is the right way to approach time
pressure very well let's have you looked
at Geoffrey Zhang and Ariane tardy
recently I think it might be headed
toward a draw
no we haven't checked that one that was
the one I think when we looked at it as
our featured game today we had said that
basically there was probably going to be
a lot of liquidation happening in that
one as we looked at it it's sort of
around this rook takes h4 moment and I
had proposed basically a long line where
basically every pawn was falling and
let's see they sort of went on that
track here and it's re declines of
repetition in order to continue playing
and instead of taking that pawn Geoffrey
plays rook age one which is probably the
key move to really hold things together
because again if we had just taken here
there's a lot of moves in play but also
whites pawns do start to fall there so
this is a really nice move that if rook
takes b7 you've got rook h7 check taking
that rook back and it just activates the
rook before we take that pawn and what
do we see here is pretty much the same
thing except white gets that extra pawn
on e6 for his trouble so it is looking
more and more like this one is headed
towards a draw as Geoffrey Zhong you
know antara are pretty much around the
same time left on the clock materials
that even there's no dangerous pass
pawns so I think this one is is pretty
even here then alright and you know that
means we still may not have a clear
writer in group a after four days as
they as they draw who can leapfrog them
in in the tournament here who also has
two points in the a group well iliyan is
Nick in the all-ukrainian
matchup right and Eve on Chuck he'd be
the only one that could actually
leapfrog to three points and the victory
and this one it looks more and more like
I mean I guess King u2 is the last move
yeah this one is looking more and more
like nothing to be afraid of for Yvonne
shakers you can actually see the
develops a look at the board if we can
and get that up there you can see the
developments here it's actually those
pawns have really banished from the port
there been so many pawns have banished
from White's position actually and the
reason that that happened was after rook
b2 again it's so hard to play this
position with white so he decided I'm
gonna do anything just to get my knight
active and both sides just started
taking all these ponds and what White is
relying on is basically if you play
let's say Knight takes before I would
always have a long-term something like 9
f6 and usually in these positions you
can arrange a drop by taking the pawn
and coming back and just giving enough
checks to the King that there's no way
to no way to get out of that but that
being said Yvonne chick doesn't really
have anything to be concerned about the
players have hit time control I think
the most likely result for this would be
a draw but it depends how ambitious want
one or both of these players get well
then that would mean no leapfrogging
today right now that's that's what it's
looking like here so far okay so we've
covered every game at least for a little
bit like can we check back in with Kozma
Jenna I'm sorry okay
Kasim jonov and Liam Lee let's take a
look I understand they're about to draw
they're repeating hides on apologies I
misheard
Gregory kadam's game in Group B right I
guess not reversed bullets this one is
looking like probably still in the
Kwan's favor which is what we had seen
before but nothing decisive yet but
Kasim jonov has his work cut out from
there over in the B group the game
between
was it Gregory Qaeda Navi is black
against Breyers wall that's right this
one I was thinking look at it here and
you know I'm saying everywhere every kid
has the fantasy of just playing Queen g3
and Bishop h3 and you know there's so
many pins in the position you can't take
any of my pieces even though it looks
like you can but I'm sure they're very
tactical reasons why that just doesn't
work and as a result Queen c1 queen f4
and I mean here it's it's almost too bad
that cuyana has to take a draw or so it
would seem because if you didn't have to
I'd almost prefer the e bishops but the
problem is this pawn is so hard to
defend and if you play Bishop c5 there's
Queen c7 because you're not covering
that anymore so maybe he can play what's
the only move here like Queen c5 maybe
Queen c5 can be played because I'm
looking at Queen c5 here first of all
I'm looking at this repetition and I'm
saying that that this looks like he's
using the repetition in order to gain
some moves towards move for you it seems
to me like if black can arrange a queen
trade he's doing much better in the
position so I would expect guidon out to
give real thoughts of Queen c5 you have
to find a move that deals with Queen c7
check Queen takes a7 check watches your
Bishop sort of like does everything at
once in Queen c5 seems to be one of the
ways to do that you're hitting the Queen
and you're hitting that Knight now for
white here there's actually not much I
can do about that unless this insane
move somehow it works but no then
there's just there's just no way the
very least I have Queen back so no if
that doesn't work I mean we're gonna see
Queen c5 on the board because it's just
forces of Queen exchange and if I can
force a Queen exchange here then I'm
hitting this pawn I've got the outside
pawn and I've got the two bishops here
so in fact yes Queen c5 is on the board
so yes he was just using the repetition
and gained some time on the clock and
waste some moves before move 40 is now
there
37 approaching 38 he's gonna make time
control no problem here and I think
Kadena is gonna be pushing it's a very
very small advantage because I just
prefer the bishops got that outside
passed on but probably should still be a
draw
but he's gonna push this I think a
little bit yeah he'll need to if he
wants any result other than that Queen
e1 has just been played by the former GB
chains it's not like that end game with
the two Bishop so he's trying to keep
the Queens on and and the put the play
continues so maybe not an immediate draw
there let's jump over to korilla and
theodoro also in Group D bishops of
opposite colors but is it a draw an
endgame it looks like there's really
good chances here and actually as we saw
earlier that position developed exactly
as I thought it was actually white
gaining the upper hand here is that
Bishop h3 move came in rook h1 all the
moves that that looks scary Bishop takes
f5 and yeah White was actually crashing
through here had to be careful about the
clock but I think with what the bishops
of off the opposite colors and the rooks
on the board
white would like to claim that you know
if you can just get that pawn to g5 it's
nearly a checkmate on the board but you
have to be careful Bishop f2 is a threat
hitting that pawn as well as this sort
of outside a pawn that could start
running here but I would say big
improvement for korilla as we saw him
down to like minute earlier on the King
was running around but he's really
improved his position and I think that I
think that White's doing quite well here
Ben all right you know we talked about
korilla I think it was on day one him
starting the new mazu chess team right
so it can only be good publicity with a
good showing here yes way to lead by
example yes
lead by example the throwing its hat
into the chess the college chess ring
it's Missouri and it's universities
especially here in st. Louis are no
stranger to that right
it's getting stronger and stronger here
all of the games are still happening in
group a nothing has ended right well I'm
pretty sure that that niche Nick and
Yvonne trick is I mean I don't know if
it's about to end but I can just safely
say that I believe is this a draw agreed
there's this a checkmate I think he just
made it himself he thought oh that does
look mate like mate oh my gosh I think
he just made it himself
Wow Christine korilla mate in the board
yeah actually
Bishop d5 was played rook takes b3 King
h5 was played because it's actually just
it's actually just rook f7 made so well
it's not made on board here it is game
over and it was unstoppable meat right
now after king h5 taking me the last
square for the King you had to play King
at five
Brooke f7 if Bishop f6 we're gonna see
g4 takes and hey that's a free bishop
and a game over
so gorilla bounces back here with a win
he takes out the leader of Group B and
let's see a Nick in Nicholas theodora's
Armour there the position looked really
tough as he got in time pressure the
King was exposed but as I was saying he
really brought it together and it
actually looked good for korilla as long
as he could manage the time it looks
like he did and now gorilla right now in
the live standings is also at the top of
Group B with that victory so congrats to
him by Jin Chi versus Sergei Ehrenburg
Group B action by Jin she is now rolling
is he rolling let's take a look so I
think he's good he went for f4 and the
only important question is actually
Bishop g6 now essentially if I can play
a five here as white game over no
questions asked King F for these pawns
role the only question I have is about
Bishop g6 if I can sort of establish
some sort of light square block he is my
only hope here the first move that comes
to mind is maybe e6 by white maybe we
want to just run that pawn get it all
the way to e7 bring the rook down the
other idea is rook to d6 what happens
after this
and we prevent the move f5 from
happening that's the real question
I I don't think so that rook might be
coming to f6 it depends where the King
goes but there's rook d7 if King g7 as
well a lot of pawns are falling and it's
actually played on the board Bishop d6 I
think it's the only realistic sort of
human try here you have to stop those
ponds and we're gonna see bhaijan she
probably just maybe sink into a bit of
calculation but have thought here but I
think he he knows that this position is
winning for white and with a little
technique here whether it's rook d6
and rook f6 or maybe II 6 on the board
I'm sure that there's a way for for
white to just crash through here I would
feel confident playing this against
Sergei Arenberg and I'm the 1,400 in the
room I'm feeling really good about this
position for bhaijan sheet right it's
got your approval they're back I mean I
think that's going through that's the
index we're working with you okay I'm
sure
bhaijan she's scratching his head right
now it's like what would Ben say what
Ben Simon say about this position right
here that's right yeah that's exactly it
that move right there he's got it all
thanks to you he played an even stronger
move which I am probably okay so Bishop
takes f5 and Barrett's not to have
suggested but f5 is actually a simpler
version of absolutely everything that I
was discussing okay you can't prevent f5
by even attacking the square and then
you're just toast here takes we're gift
to is there's nothing more there's
nothing more to this one and if you
don't take then your move Bishop d6 is
even worse so we'll actually probably
see honestly resignation just on the
board there there's there's no playing
on for this all right
news Nick and Eve on show calves drawn
their game has that make sense we
speculated yep so it looks like in the
in the B group there's the Caetano of
game who he decided to play on instead
of repeating and korilla has defeated
the adoro as we saw so only two games
left Oh
yeah two games left here yeah so this
game is probably gonna end and then
they'll just be cut down ups game left
but I think we'll probably see a
resignation on this board any second
here as he's faced with f5 on the board
you just played a move that looked like
it stopped f5 so when you leave the
board you clear your head okay let me
see if I can draw this you come back and
f5 sitting there no you just gotta throw
in the towel here there's there's
nothing to do Rae Robson and Benjamin
Bach that is the one that interests me
right now in Group A yep this one is
this is the one where you've got the
bishop against the pawns and long-term
Ray's gonna try to convert this Benjamin
is trying to hold steady here he's
gotten rid of the F pawn now what also
has to happen is he needs to get rid of
this punk because depending on where
this pawn is banned there's also certain
positions where let's imagine that all
four of these pawns disappear in
exchange for the F pawn
if this pawn is up on like h5 you can
actually put your King on h8 and even
that position is a draw rook Bishop and
pawn against the rook if that pawn is
too far up the board it's actually a
draw there as well but if the plant is
sits on h3 I actually saw onigiri
convert an endgame like that against his
countryman Jordan van for Ace the pawn
on h3 Bishop and rook against the black
rook and that one was winning so it
really depends how far off the board
this pawn gets but no doubt these
players are trying to access those sort
of index of maybe studies or anything
that they've seen before where they can
definitively say that this position is a
draw this position is a win and try to
convert it to those more familiar
patterns I understand that we have the
count Grandmaster Christian korilla
ready for an interview so I will be back
after that awesome and in the meantime
there is still this game between Hansen
and a Cobian taking place in the a group
and it looks like the worst is over for
for erosion of Cobian who has survived
the time pressure
they've just hit move 40 that was moved
44 White Queen D 5 and then a 5 played
by Eric so this position we have on the
board here Eric's just played the move a
5 now it's it's a little tough to get
these pawns going but what he would like
to do in a lot of positions is see if he
can organize a Queen trade now a co
beans position I think has improved
tremendously from the time scramble that
he was in earlier where right now we see
his pieces pinned so that's why f7 is
not hanging just yet however he has he
has sort of improved the activity of his
pieces here at the price of upon and
what it looked like earlier was that
that a Cobian was maybe gonna go down
even in based on the time pressure and
the threats that Hansen was able to
create against the king there so
actually a co bean seems to have done
quite well to survive till here what he
needs to be careful of is potentially a
Queen trade Queen trade in the position
maybe Eric is able to use these outside
pass pawn potential and grind down a
long endgame ahead but like I said I
think that the worst is over for var who
has hit move 40 and and this looks
promising for him but in the meantime we
are joined by Grandmaster Christian
korilla welcome to the studio first time
no good see you know you just came off a
win against Nicholas Theodore who was
leading the B group so he was off to a
tremendous start and you took down the
leader in a game that looked like at the
start your king was going for a job yeah
I have no idea what was happening to be
honest we played some very enterprising
chests from the beginning it looked like
you know he started off with this
maneuver 96-97 which I've never seen in
my life
right it looked it looks so so tame at
the start just a London system but then
the fireworks started so if you wouldn't
mind you know I see the law in the
system for you oh I know you're an
expert you know we've been looking at
this London system to know a little bit
yeah you know so I'm trying to emulate
mr. handle
some of the the the greatest talents of
today's generation but yes this started
off as a London system you with white
pieces so what he generally does in the
opening he generally does g6 so this is
why I played the London because
generally he likes to go into the Kings
Indian structures he puts the pawn on g6
and if it goes g6 probably I will go
Knight c3 and then we get he's forced
play d5 almost forced play d5 even if he
allows me to go here for then white has
a very nice position and I was just
trying to get him out of his his usual
play you know I was trying I was trying
to get the structures that don't
necessarily apply to his repertoire
mm-hmm right and most g6 players whether
you want to play a king zener you're not
used to they love to keep the pawn on d6
and Brady five at some point right so
okay I mean he played these six right
which I'm more or less expected on some
degree III and now ninety sixty I've
never see those of you guys were yeah so
I go I went night the night of three
ninety seven and now obviously he wants
to put the night on g6 right so I
decided to have some fun with it and
regulate h4 not h3 with h4 and now we
get a very fun looking position well the
thing is if he goes Niger six I'm
planning to go Bishop g5 and then h6 I
take on f6 and then h5 and then his
position is a little bit packed on the
Kings side right yeah
his knight has to go back then I can go
if or at some point I don't even have to
go in for a 93 for at some point it just
seems like he needs another at least
three moves to get his pieces out right
it felt just dangerous for him yeah so
he decided to go be six makes a lot of
sense
c4 Bishop d7 Knight c3 so far so good
Knight a5 again the same idea if he goes
96 I go Bishop g5 yeah h5 I think he
wanted to go Knight h5 I'm not her son
sure so that's why I play they try for
example if I go something like Bishop d3
I was in Harrison sure how does
is after night age five because okay
bishop age two he can take on h4 right
yeah so I think I'm losing my bishop at
least maybe it was still fine just to
leave the bishop on f4 but it seemed
like maybe h5 looks threatening and
maybe he's gonna get scared right get
something out of it right Bishop d6 sure
Oh actually suddenly this position looks
like the strangest orientation of pieces
in the center yeah I know 95 I think was
bad f3 + f6 yeah I think he's already
getting a very nice position here 95
didn't feel right I think Bishop g5 is
probably the better move threatening
Bishop takes f6 and E 4 right so I think
what he was mentioning was Bishop b4 in
this position this one looks maybe Queen
b3 maybe Bishop d3 I mean I have a lot
of ways the thing is yeah I would love
to get control over those light squares
in the center and play d4 at the right
moment right like Bishop d3 obviously I
think he was mentioning h6 in this
position and I don't think I'm getting
it for because Bishop takes f6 Queen f6
if or he takes on d4 so I'm not getting
there
you know I'm close but not getting there
maybe I just have to play it simple
Queen c2 maybe try to exchange the light
square bishop so we'd be shot before or
maybe even Queen between before but
obviously a very very complicated middle
game yeah I played 95 which was not
amazing 94 94 Bishop before f3 f6 I kind
of underestimated this right I thought
he's going to go back to b7 and then I'm
going to go g4 yeah that position yeah
f6 take on f5 take only 5 take only 5 we
should be for King F to take on f5 and
now I think he's going to have a very
difficult position of their Bishop d3
castle Queen c2 and then I just want to
go rugae g1
you're going to get killed down on the
kingside now that looks yeah and my king
on f2 is actually perfectly safe doing
well yes yeah so okay I mean obviously
he he didn't go for this f6 which is a
very strong move and now this stuff more
or less first I mean everything just
sorta yeah I was initially I want to
take on e4 mm-hmm
have takes e4 take on 5d takes d5 bishop
before King f29 h6 then I realized those
ones are looking quite funny my bishop
one f4 is actually not doing anything
and it's not going to do anything for a
very long time right if I don't take on
h6 then the bishop on e4 is going to be
stuck there sure and if I take on f6
then still my pieces don't get to his
King yeah yeah he castles and checks you
he cancels me I think I have to put the
bishop on f3 and once again is the
difference between the bishops yeah
obviously in his favor so yeah I decided
take on f5 and kind of pull the brakes
all right in the mindset of trying to
get equality already I think I'm
slightly worse already yeah that's what
it looked like but I think there was a
moment where I mean you were quite quite
long time as yeah so the I'm pressure
all feeling a factor yeah I sent a lot
of time trying to understand this
position efore was an idea Queen f3 was
an idea h6 was an idea with the Queen on
d1 right and I try to give the check on
h5 you know there's a lot of things to
calculate but I'm not going to go into
those issues let's go to Queen f3 just
normal normal moves Bishop before Queen
f6 right rook d1 route 88 I think this
was a good move for him because I don't
actually have a very useful move no
however it looked like the move each six
kind of worked out for you in the end
yeah the way that it happened I think
you have to take on h6 right is there it
was there an improvement you you saw for
him because I just stuff there h6 they
take the pawn just take it it seems to
have more cushion on the H file you know
I have to go through once yeah break
through twice
and he can always defend that one maybe
we even with King g7 at the right moment
who kept seven Bishop a faith
potentially I mean the ponen on the dark
square I think it's much more safe than
on the light square right it actually
seemed in a game like this Bishop on
before needed a home yeah it didn't have
a place to go so maybe here Bishop f8
actually yeah he wants to put it on the
long diagonal and know it might be for
pawn because if I go d5 then I weaken my
position right tremendously right so I'm
not sure I think after eight after
taking on h6 maybe I would have taken on
e6 but still Quint except for I'm not
really sure how to assess that that end
game because Queen takes therefore I
cannot take on d7 because of Queen III
so maybe he didn't react here because
here's a lot he had a lot of time as
well yeah in this position so maybe just
miss evaluated something also the queen
is much better place don't have six down
on g7 mm-hmm so he's kind of losing on
two fronts right yeah so I think this
was critical but yes right now I'm
starting to attack his pawns on the
light squares and I'm not 100% sure how
he defends them yeah it seems to me like
after g3 I mean the coordination is all
of a sudden it sits there for you no
matter how you cut it is that this pawn
is falling in h7 is well the thing is
he's losing a pawn for example if he
goes I know Bishop d6 Bishop h3 and now
he doesn't have a way to defend the pawn
because Queen g6 I go route g5 right and
then he has to put the Queen on e6 but
then I can start doing Queen d3 and I
think the point is falling ya know
unless there's sacrifices I mean the
King's actually remarkably safe I have
to yeah so by this moment maybe he's
already in emergency mode and has to go
Ruki for right maybe this was one of the
moves I considered here Ruka v I think
this is what he missed initially but now
after just through takes d4 maybe this
is the best way to go Roe takes the
faith Bishop takes f8
yeah it seems like this one should
should get equal very quickly maybe just
be three and then you know I don't think
any any of the sites has anything at
this point right yeah that's what it
looked like as after push me is having
it seemed to shake completely ya know
after we should be suing I think the
game is is very close to being over
because Nisha pastry queen g6 seems to
be like the only way to defend that pawn
yeah and I he miss Rooke h6 so Bishop f6
Bishop takes f5 Bishop takes d4 King g2
and our rook takes a five rocked x h7
King g8 and now work one h6 right this
is what he missed his queen is actually
trapped and if it takes on h7 the key is
that I take take Queen d3 I pin him on
on that diagonal and g4 is coming
getting the rookin and the game is over
actually I was wondering whether whether
this is a fourth dress or not so look a
fake g4 let's say these Sixers actually
you don't have time for these six these
six taken if I've taken be too but I
have f6 yeah f6 he doesn't have time to
take the pawn on if you can get the pond
and then there's real chances maybe for
some I think so I think so maybe put the
rook on f7 bishop on f6 and just stay
like this turtle
yeah but f6 f6 is otherwise he has to
try it with the pawn there and then no
Barry yeah yeah and after that I think
the endgame is just uh yeah all this
stuff was actually pretty forcing more
or less and you had salt or your time
table yeah and when the moves are this
easy very easy at this point yeah yeah
that was kind of a relief for me as well
yeah yeah you survived the storm and and
then the opposite bishop endgame I mean
it's opposite bishops but it should just
the thing is he has to always stay here
connected to my g3 pawn or keep my king
on on the fourth-ranked
with with his king yeah if I manage to
go king g5 or king of five and start
pushing my pawns yep the game is over
that's too much
so he he did his best to do that yeah as
he sort of there he was cutting you off
with the King and then he tried to bring
the rook to the third-ranked but then he
missed king h5 t h5 is a really nice way
to have the game there yes you just box
him in all around yeah yeah you know
five and then of course here we should
have six just g4 and growth takes over
six yeah so actually the game really
flipped around because it looked like
you were in times probably you were
scrambling yeah and all of a sudden the
opposite bishops paid off as you were
delivering the attack yeah yeah yeah
yeah I think also g3 was a pretty decent
move yes the g3 moved it's actually
secured everything secures the king
because I can always go to GG - and even
h3 in some cases and opens up this idea
of Bishop h3 and attack the pawn on f5
via that diagonal right because on d3 or
obviously my pawn on d4 is always an e
right now I was saying that I mean
Nikolas was off to a great start in the
tournament but you were able to stop the
train before before it got going so
obviously taking down the leader in the
section and getting a win for yourself
and putting tournament back on track
congratulations thank you thanks for
joining us John that was Grandmaster
Christian korilla taking us through his
win against Nicholas theodoro in the B
section here at the spring chess classic
and what come back that game was as it
didn't look good early on but he was
able to turn the game around completely
and come away with a victory
taking down Theodora who was atop the
leaderboard so far so that really shakes
up the standings there in Group B a few
games still in progress here Gregory
katana against baarish pullets is still
in progress in the B group we also had a
I believe we had a result yes that was
of course right before we jumped into
that analysis Jin sheep I did win his
game as Arenberg resigned that position
which was completely lost
after f5 nanak and yvonne shook we
mentioned
drew their game and still still in
progress we have Benjamin Bach Ray
Robson tari against Geoffrey Zhang as
well as Hanson against a co bein so
still some games in progress to take a
look at it definitely looked like Sergei
Arenberg was spooked by that f5 move and
yeah as we thought it was a resignation
right well guys I've been looking on US
chess champs calm and I just noticed we
are only 15 days away from the US
Champion that's right
and we're gonna have three of the
competitors in the a field play in that
event but you're also gonna have Fabiano
Cara Juana
you're gonna have Hikaru Nakamura Wesley
so joined this year for the first time
formerly of Cuba linear Dominguez and of
course the defending US Champion herself
the unlikely hero of last year Sam
Shanklin they'll be joined by seven
other players in a 12 player round-robin
and also at the same time the US Women's
Championship naazy Paquita is not
defending her title this year so we are
gonna have a brand new US Women's
Champion it all begins round number one
on Wednesday March 20th just 15 days
away it's exciting I mean it's just a
busy chess month here here in st. Louis
a great time to visit
it's a busy chess year you know we used
to say oh the US Championship is coming
up it's like chess Christmas here in st.
Louis well maybe I don't want to say
lost in the shuffle but there's
definitely more to fill the calendar now
that's right but the US Championship is
near and dear to all of our hearts here
at the st. Louis chess club I'd like I
know we only have one game finished in
Group A in the Spring Classic today but
if we have any kind of results or
standings its standings let's take a
look at our standings they're not much
different than what we saw at the top of
the show because we only have one draw
to add Tunisia Nick's score and Yvonne
Chuck's score Jeffery Zhang and Aria and
tari look like they they still look like
they're gonna draw here zhang atari I
was just checking that game I mean it
definitely looks like
it's going towards a dry dough can't see
anything between the two players you
know that one I mean it's the most
likely result but with the game still
going I guess technically anything can
happen yeah and who knows maybe Ray
Robson will join them may I have a
four-way right tie at the top after four
rounds have been completed
let's glance over at Group B where only
one game remains today a little bit of a
clearer picture as by Jin she continues
to remain consistent at the top and he
is our first clear leader in either
section right for the spring chess
classic can he be stopped Imam I mean
it's gonna take something special so far
there doesn't appear to be any big holes
in his game and you know even when he's
not winning which hasn't happened very
often
he has never really looked in danger and
I think that's when the players in the
group are gonna be feeling like they can
beat him a bit more when they finally
see him in danger
maybe I've prepared maybe low on the
clock we just haven't seen anything so
far that would indicate that so it's a
long tournament and if you can remain
out of any of that sort of danger for
the whole time that's extremely
impressive so we'll see and tomorrow is
another day
another round here are the pairings for
tomorrow in our masters division group a
a von Schuch versus Kasim Jean of Bach
versus music
tari vs. Robson that could be a key
matchup right there if both players are
in the lead with two and a half points
it depends on how Robson scores in his
game that's going on right now against
Bach Eric Hanson vs. Jeffrey Zhang and
Liam Lee versus var OCO Beyond and here
are the pairings for group B tomorrow hi
donal of stein Grimson Ehrenburg Park
Barse pullets the Adaro versus by ginchy
Sorokin versus korilla and vista versus
kendra it's nice to talk to mr. today
yeah it's nice to nice to hear his his
thoughts there and he himself was able
to find the the comic humor and in his
last loss versus today's win which was
nice to see and yeah he's very
well-spoken it's nice to hear from them
and we hope that you join us again
tomorrow same time same place
3:30 p.m. central is when the show
starts but 1:00 p.m. Central is when the
games start and you can see it all as it
happens at u.s. chess champs calm the
show was produced by the world's
greatest production B team Tammy Hyde is
streaming the show Dani Machuca is your
technical director Isaac Krantz is audio
and graphics and my name is Ben Simon
and he's the guy with the purple hair
the chest bra one of them I don't want
to reserve that name exclusively for you
know we disrespect to Eric Hanson or
anybody else right but one of just 50%
great Grandmaster I'm on Hamilton and
until tomorrow we say so long from the
show-me-state this has been a
presentation of the st. Louis chess club
you